I don't believe that power should pass
basically from one nepotism baby to the
next there is no inherent qualification
that they have that means that they have
a divine right to rule do you give the
king any credit for a slim down monarchy
A vastly reduced guest list compared to
the coronation of his mother is he not
making an effort
no
Smith they would recognize where their
wealth and power comes from which is
colonization they would give back jaws
and artifacts that they have stolen they
would cancel or Lobby to cancel
countries debts and reparations that
they've destroyed through colonization
and they would abolish the monarchy that
to me would be trying you know we picked
today it's an incredibly expensive
coronation procession up to a quarter of
a billion pounds in the middle of a cost
of living crisis I think a lot of people
are shocked by that and I think what's
really been shown over the last few
weeks is there isn't that much public
support for the monarchy anymore
certainly less than they thought I think
the polls have changed quite a lot and
when they've asked people to for example
give an oath of Allegiance a lot of
people have turned around and said you
know we're not going to do that you know
we see ourselves as Citizens we don't
want to swear fealty to you so I think I
think times have changed a lot since the
1950s it's the last coronation and
that's really been shown up recently so
we're here today to you know make our
voices loud and heard to represent all
the people in this country the growing
number of
who want to see an end to the monarchy